so with just 10 days to go until cop26
it's been confirmed that india's prime
minister narendra modi will travel to
glasgow for the summit downing street
has welcomed the news saying india has a
vital role in making the event a success
but who really holds the power to create
change so bob how significant do you
think it is that narendra modi is
heading to glasgow
well it is very significant because it
raises the prospect that he may make
major announcement about india's uh
emissions at the moment we haven't seen
a revised more ambitious pledge from
india which all countries were supposed
to bring forward before glasgow but the
fact that he will be in glasgow in
person means that he may make an
announcement and some of the discussion
has been about the possibility of india
committing to a net zero target getting
its emissions down to zero perhaps by
2060. so all of this is very exciting
well yes that's right and it's true
isn't it that india hasn't yet announced
plans to reach net zero so vikki
india's under pressure to make that move
if they were to
would that put pressure on other
countries like china to take
a different stance and to up their game
well the interesting thing is of course
that china has already announced that
they are also aiming for net zero by
2060 so it would be india that would be
following more what china has done
already uh but the reality is that quite
a lot of other developing countries
might look at that and and realize that
they can't be out on their own really in
this area but there is going to be a
price i think that is going to be
extracted for pledging net zero for
india it is after all the third largest
carbon emission uh country in the world
and and of course it will cost it a lot
to move away from its over reliance for
example right now still on coal despite
the the progress that it has made in
terms of renewables so it is going to be
asking for cash i'm pretty certain all
other conditions to be met that would be
beneficial to india if it is indeed
going to move in that direction cannot
do it i think on the basis of where
things are at present well yes and
climate finance is going to be a huge
part of the discussion in glasgow isn't
it bob so india's presence how does that
affect that debate and how does that
feed into everything else
well india is a developing country it's
much poorer than the rich countries and
what it's saying to the world is look
at the moment it costs more for it to to
access capital to make the kind of
investments needed in renewables and
others and it's it's that capital is
more expensive because it's considered
to be a more risky place to do it and
because renewable energy is considered
more risky so it's going to say to the
rich world please help us access this
capital so that we can access it the the
private sector will make money on this
because it's built it will be building
an energy system that will generate
returns so it should be
an attractive prospect both for the
private sector and the public sector and
we all benefit if india does start to
limit its emissions
you